لكن هل تعلم أن كوكب المريخ ، أقرب
جيراننا في النظام الشمسي ، يعاني أيضًا من
جليد ثلجي وشتاء حقيقي
[موسيقى]
المريخ مكان جاف جدًا ولكن إذا ذهبت
إلى المواقع الصحيحة ستجد
جليدًا مائيًا تمامًا مثل ذلك  لدينا على
الأرض ولكن أيضًا جليد ثاني أكسيد الكربون أو جليد جاف
أجنبي
ER ، لاحظت بعثة ناسا التي وصلت إلى المريخ
في عام 2008
المناظر الطبيعية الصقيعية الجميلة التي تشكلت حولها ،
لا يذوب جليد ثاني أكسيد الكربون بدلاً من ذلك ، بل
يعود من الحالة الصلبة إلى الغاز مباشرة في
الغلاف الجوي مما يؤدي
لتشكيل ميزات سطحية فريدة حقًا ،
على سبيل المثال ، نرى
ميزات على شكل عنكبوت
[موسيقى]
البذور عبارة عن جليد مائي أسفل الأرض مباشرةً ،
وهذا هو نوع الجليد المائي الذي
يمكن لرواد الفضاء استخدامه في
المستقبل عندما نذهب إلى هناك
[موسيقى]